We often think of
a Bernoulli process
as a stream of arriving traffic.
What happens if we
merge two streams?
For example, consider a
server that receives traffic
from two independent sources.
How do we describe
the total traffic
that arrives to this server?
Here's a precise model.
We have two streams
that correspond
to Bernoulli processes with
some parameters each, p and q,
respectively.
And each one of these
processes receives arrivals
at certain times that
we indicate by crosses;
and similarly, for
the second process.
We assume that these two
processes are independent.
And what we mean by this
is that any collection
of random variables associated
with the first process
will be independent from any
collection of random variables
associated with
the second process.
We now merge the two
processes as follows.
Whenever there's an arrival in
any of the original processes,
we record an arrival
in the merged process,
as in this picture.
Notice that we do not to make a
distinction between those slots
at which there was
an arrival in only
one of the original
[processes] versus those slots
in which there was an arrival in
both of the original processes.
In both cases, we
just say that there
was an arrival in
the merged process,
and so collisions--
arrivals in both
of the original
processes-- are counted
as only one arrival
in the merged process.
Now, what can we say
about the merged process?
We will argue that
it is a Bernoulli
process with a certain
parameter that we will compute.
To check the Bernoulli property
for the merged process,
the first thing
we need to ensure
is the independence assumption,
independence across slots.
Let us look at
two typical slots.
And to do this, it helps
to define some notation
that Xt and Yt be the
original processes,
and let Zt be the
merged process.
The random variable Zt
is determined in some way
by the random
variables Xt and Yt.
If I tell you there was
an arrival in the first
and to the second
process, you can
tell whether there was an
arrival in the merged process.
And similarly, the
random variable Zt plus 1
is determined in some way
from Xt plus 1 and Yt plus 1.
What this is saying
is that whether we
have an arrival at
this slot is determined
by what happens in
these two slots.
And whether we have an
arrival in this slot
is determined by whatever
happens in these two slots.
Now, we have assumed that the
two processes are independent.
So these two random
variables are
independent from those
two random variables.
And furthermore, across
time, this random variable
will be independent from
that random variable.
And this random variable
will be independent
from that random variable.
So these four random variables
are independent of each other.
Because of this, we
have Zt, a function
of two random variables that
are independent from the two
random variables that
determine Zt plus 1.
And for this reason, Zt and
Zt plus 1 will be independent.
This proves a pairwise
independence property
for the merged process, but
we can extend this argument
to argue that the collection of
random variables, Z1 up to Zt,
is a collection of
independent random variables.
So we have the
independence property.
Now, let us calculate the
probability of an arrival
during a typical slot.
During a typical
time slot, there
are four possibilities
for what may occur.
And these possibilities
have to do with
whether in the X process,
we have an arrival
or not; and in the Y process,
whether we have an arrival
or not.
The probability that we have
an arrival in both processes,
because of independence, is
the product of the probability
that we have an arrival
in the first process
with the probability
that we have
an arrival in the
second process.
Similarly, there's
a probability p
of an arrival in
the first process
and no arrival in the second.
There's a probability
1 minus p of no arrival
in the first process
and [a probability q of]
an arrival in the
second process.
And finally, there is
probability 1 minus p times 1
minus q of no arrival in
either of the two processes.
The probability that we have an
arrival in the merged process
is the probability
of this green event.
These are the cases in
which an arrival gets
recorded in the merged process.
So the probability of an
arrival in the merged process
is the sum of those
three probabilities.
Or another way to calculate
it is 1 minus this probability
here; namely, 1 minus 1
minus p times 1 minus q.
And after you
expand this product
and do some
cancellations, you end up
with this expression, which is
the probability of an arrival
during a slot in
the merged process.
Of course, this probability
is constant across time.
And this, together with
the independence property,
establishes that the
merged process is actually
a Bernoulli process.
Now, let us end by
answering one more question.
If I tell you that at
a certain time slot,
there was at least one arrival
in the two processes, which
means that there was an
arrival in the merged process,
what is the
probability that there
was an arrival in
the first process?
Now, the event that there was
an arrival in the first process
is this event here.
So we're trying to calculate
the conditional probability
of the blue event given that
the green event has occurred.
We use the definition of
conditional probabilities.
A conditional probability
is equal to the probability
that both events happen,
which in this case
is the intersection of the
blue and the green event,
which coincides
with the blue event.
And the probability
of the blue event
is the sum of these two
numbers, is equal to p.
And then we divide by the
probability of the conditioning
event, this is the
probability of an arrival.
But this is what we
have just calculated,
which is p plus q
minus p times q.